[Musique]
je m'appelle charlotte et je pense que
les plus belles découvertes se font au
bout de la rue ce que j'aime c'est
découvrir notre beau pays avec des
personnes exceptionnelles et souvent
insolites
alors je vous emmène avec moi je vous
retrouve aujourd'hui à rambouillet dans
les yvelines et si rambouillet célèbre
c'est peut-être pour sa forêt mais
surtout pour son château à votre avis
quel est le point commun entre françois
1er
marie antoinette et valéry giscard
d'estaing eh bien ils ont tous séjourné
ici en vacances ou en week end au
château de rambouillet alors pourquoi
ils ont été charmés par ce lieu dont va
découvrir ça avec and play
[Musique]
la première chose qu'on voit quand on
arrive ici au château à rambouillet
c'est cet ensemble alors composé de
quand même deux choses très différentes
qui datent de quelle époque
alors c'est vrai quand on arrive on se
pose souvent la question des visiteurs
comprennent pas toujours
en fait on a d'abord cette énorme tour
qui nous rappellent le passé du
moyen-âge le château qui a été conçu au
moyen-âge au xvème siècle
et puis ensuite on a des partis qui ont
été restaurées au fil du temps par
exemple toute cette partie-là les
façades sont d'époque napoléon 1er alors
en quelques mots le château de
rambouillet c'est avant tout quoi c'est
avant tout un voyage dans le temps un
voyage dans le temps et dans l'intimité
des grands personnages de l'histoire de
france
rambouillet ce n'est pas un château de
grandes représentations
ici les rois les reines les chefs d'état
français sont venus pour être en famille
se reposer ou encore profiter de la
forêt et de la nature
ce voyage à travers les siècles et les
puissants on commence où et quand et là
on commence au début du 19e siècle avec
napoléon 1er qui a fait de rendre une
résidence impériale un peu dans la digne
succession de ses prédécesseurs parce
que c'était déjà une résidence royale
avant la mousson française et on est ici
dans un appartement qu'il avait demandé
de réaménager entièrement aux goûts de
l'époque
donc là on est dans la chambre de
l'empereur napoléon 1er du mobilier
d'époque de l'acajou des belles dorures
plein de choses qui nous rappelle le
retour à l'antique et napoléon par
exemple pourquoi il aimait venir ici
pour les mêmes raisons que tous les
propriétaires du chat souvent oublié au
fil du temps la première c'est qu'on
n'est pas très loin de paris à 50 km de
paris mais à la fois on est suffisamment
loin pour être tranquille c'est un lieu
où on a plein d'activités parce qu'on a
une magnifique forêt et que
cette forêt on y chasse et elle est très
très giboyeuse donc ça plaît énormément
et c'est un lieu vraiment qui permet de
s'éloigner un petit peu de des rigueurs
de l'étiquette parisienne dont l'écran
deux résidentes qui pourtant tu parles
et d'intimité aussi c'est qu'on peut
exactement
on est vraiment ici on sent chaque
propriétaire va venir avec sa famille
ses proches
on va organiser des petits repas alors
ça n'empêche que napoléon était
quelqu'un qui travaille est
perpétuellement donc il a son bureau
juste avant et il y travaille mais par
contre on est tout le temps avec ses
proches et on perçoit ici à l'intimité
qu'on aperçoit le napoléon bonaparte
l'homme plutôt que l'emprunt je tiens à
huy donc l'intimité voilà la salle de
bain on peut pas être plus intimes alors
une salle de bain quand même où il ya on
rappelle que c'est la série de bande en
puissance à la c
ces charges et c'est déjà faut savoir
que c'est exceptionnel c'est de pouvoir
conserver un décor de salle de bain
comme ça donc on a vraiment beaucoup de
chance à rambouillet et est donc
effectivement c'est un décor qui est
extrêmement chargé août à toute la
puissance de l'emprunt napoléon 1er qui
est manifestée là par exemple assure ce
premier panneau tu retrouves à des
grandes victoires italiennes de naples
et de sicile une mention de la
constitution de lempire le traité damien
voilà clairement tu as raison on pose
les bases du succès de la gloire de
l'empereur donc dans une salle de bain
c'est c'est assez étrange parce que
c'est par un lieu de représentation
c'est un lieu d'intimité mais ça devrait
leur assurer peut-être quand il se rase
et le matin de se dire ouais je suis
quand même quelqu'un de fées tête bat
toute manière c'est soit l'initiative de
l'artiste soit effectivement ça laisse
apercevoir un trait de caractère de
l'empereur on sait qu'il était de toute
manière un peu comme ça voilà un
magnifique un magnifique décor avec des
panneaux différents qui sont tous
inspirés de l'art antique
c'est la grande mode du néoclassicisme à
cette époque et je sais pas si tu te
rends compte mais là on a voulu
s'inspirer un peu de pompéi où on est
vraiment sur fond de peinture un peu au
krylia des animaux mythologiques
dessiner un petit peu partout on
continue la découverte en visitant ce
charmant boudoir résultat de l'histoire
d'amour du comte de toulouse fils de
louis xiv pour marie victoire sophie de
noailles une très belle histoire que
nous raconte anne claire et que vous
pourrez retrouver en bonus sur notre
site internet ter de france pointent tv
après l'empereur et les rois le château
devient une résidence présidentielle
d'abord comme lieu de villégiature des
présidents français pour ensuite devenir
le lieu des chasses présidentielles ou
encore pour accueillir les chefs d'état
étrangers et organiser de grandes
rencontres internationales du 20e siècle
ici on est dans la grande salle à manger
des présidents de la république en
s'armant la pièce officielle on faisait
des gaules est beau bon hockey et figure
toi qu'on a fait un partenariat avec les
visées mobilier national
en fin 2017 pour pouvoir reconstituer la
table qui est derrière moi qui ai la
table du g6 le tout premier g6 qui a été
organisée par valéry giscard d'estaing
au château en 1975 alors il fallait
faire quoi pour être invités au château
pour être invité à l'époque
présidentielle à il fallait être un
proche du président de la république
parce qu'à l'origine c'était une
résidence d'été des présidents et à
partir de 11 à dire vraiment charles de
gaulle on va commencer à devenir un lieu
officiel d'accueil des chefs d'état
étrangers
donc là c'est toutes les grandes
rencontres internationales du 20e qui
ont dû au château de rambouillet comme
le g6 et par exemple les accords du
kosovo en 1995 qui est venu six mois
qu'il n'hésitera pas à tous les
présidents américains kennedy les
bouches
tu as la reine d'angleterre nelson
mandela voilà et le dernier étant
monsieur poutine
avant son accession au pouvoir donc en
2009 est ce qu'il reste encore des
choses de l'époque de françois 1er
alors oui d'ailleurs c'est bien ce lien
parce que justement figure toi que la
chambre qui avait été aménagée pour les
chefs d'état étrangers à l'époque se
trouve dans la pièce dans laquelle on
nous dit que françois 1er serait mort il
est mort au château de rambouillet ça
c'est une certitude on et 547 et on a
fixé dans la dernière pièce de la tour
du moyen-âge sa chambre on n'a aucune
certitude là dessus mais le président
étrangers qui venaient dormait dans
cette pièce dans laquelle ben françois
1er a souffert voilà depuis 2009 le
château est géré par le centre des
monuments nationaux les rois et les
présidents laisser la place aux
visiteurs aux événements culturels et
aux balades dans le parc classé jardin
remarquable
alors évidemment c'est beau en plus avec
le soleil mais moi il ya un truc qui me
fascine c'est ces petits embarcadère
comme ça je trouve que ça donne un côté
romantique ça suscite beaucoup
d'imaginaire des gentils sert en fait
les gens avant les propriétaires du
château embarquée et un petit
embarcadère là ils ont marqué sur des
barques et puis ça allait dillon ni on
organisait des petites animations des
petites fêtes tu as un truc très très
romantique et
et on a des îles qui ont été utilisés
par des personnages bien particulier par
exemple une petite île circulaire au
bout qui s'appelle lille au festin est
sûre légale napoléon venait prendre son
déjeuner tous les midis quand il était
au château de rambouillet il s'éloigne
du château car anne claire veut me faire
découvrir un véritable joyau la laiterie
de la reine d'extérieur le lieu est
impressionnant et à l'intérieur vous
allez le voir la surprise est de taille
la laiterie de main et en toile est ce
un cadeau qu'il a été fait par le roi
mais après ça servait alors les
laiteries déjà allé à l'époque de marie
antoinette c'était très très à la mode
beaucoup en avait et c'était un lieu on
pouvait se rapprocher de la nature
notamment on déguste on les bons
produits laitiers tu vois du fromage de
la crème du beurre etc
et c'était vraiment très à la mode
c'était dans l'air du temps
si tu es là tu avais tous les grands
philosophes par exemple conso qui
prônait à ce retour à la nature lui qui
s'arrêtait à toutes les fermes pour
déguster et la noblesse
elle va elle traduit sa ba commandant
marie-antoinette par exemple adorait
jouer les petite bergère au hameau de la
reine d'aller traire les vaches
à versailles et puis et puis on crée
construisent à des bâtiments pour
pouvoir vraiment déguster tu vois quel
bâtiment au crazy
on n'est pas dans le petit bâtiment
utilitaire c'est vraiment magnifique et
à cette époque aussi c'est le grand
retour de l'antiquité
donc là tu vois c'est comme si on était
dans un petit temple et qu'on pouvait
venir ici déguster imagine toi / sur les
consoles qui longe le mur la belle
vaisselle le sèvre qui contenait les
bons produits laitiers etc
c'était un moyen aussi si je me rappelle
bien de faire venir afin d'essayer de
faire venir marie-antoinette ici non à
l'est mais pas trop au départ est alors
cette laiterie oui c'est ça c'est clair
en fait quand luis saez achète le
château de rambouillet en 1583 lui il
espère venir avec ma maison soit là
dessus que marie-antoinette détesteront
bouillet surtout parce que le château à
cette énorme tour du moyen-âge sais pas
trop aller à la mode à cette époque et
du coup louis saez ne va pas désespérer
et il va décider de lui offrir un petit
yeux rien qu'à elle où elle pourra faire
ce qu elle n voilà être près de la
nature ici à rambouillet je te laisse d
besoin de cacher les yeux ou après peu
et voilà
waouh effectivement contemplation pas sa
tempe assez incroyable là tu es dans une
pièce qui s'appelle la salle des
fraîcheurs donc si tu veux tu as est
énorme grotte qui qui présentait non de
l'eau à l'intérieur de l'os est coulé
dans la grotte
ensuite l'eau venait alimenter des
petits jets d'eau de chaque côté du mur
tu vois ces petits jets d'eau eh ben on
posait dessus les les vases qui
contenait le legs qui ensuite allez être
consommée dans la première pièce mais
quand c'est vraiment une espèce de lieux
de conservation des produits laitiers
est à la fois c'est une pièce où on
pouvait s'installer sur des fauteuils et
puis découvrir des décors juste fabuleux
qui racontent des scènes de la
mythologie
cette laiterie de la reine est un lieu à
la fois surprenant et incroyable à
visiter absolument
al clair ne voulait pas me laisser
partir sans une autre découverte
étonnante
un peu plus loin dans le parc nous nous
dirigeons vers cette petite demeure que
l'on nomme la chaumière aux coquillages
alors charlotte tu t'attendais à ça
quand c'était à l'extérieur de la
chaudière en panne ont pas vraiment en
fait
ce qui est impressionnant et c'est de
voir que c'est extrêmement modestes à
l'extérieur et puis voilà et tout ça les
architectes les sculpteurs au 18e 10
soit ils sont mais trop d'illusion est
vraiment
malcom cette envie d'un retour à la
nature avec des petites maisonnettes
avec des toits de chaume
mais à l'intérieur c'est quand même
destine à la noblesse donc du coup on va
décliner un décor vraiment somptueux
t'imagines que le coquillage les gens à
l'époque il était très peu avant d'avoir
vu des vrais coquillages passé où il
n'avait pas à la mer
c'est une vraie curiosité donc citer une
richesse incroyable que d'avoir un décor
de coquillages comme ça dans une
fabrique donc s'abrite de jardin puisque
ça c'est c'est vraiment un petit
monument qui étaient là pour distraire
un peu le promeneur dans le jardin
anglais ait pu lui apporter bas un lieu
où il pouvait s'arrêter boire une tasse
de chocolat chaud de thé se détendre
avant de reprendre de reprendre la
promenade
c'est magnifique quitte à être vraiment
des coquillages qui sont à ça m'a semblé
pour faire un magnifique décor
c'est très rare c'est la seule elle est
unique en europe donc vraiment un petit
bijou
on se quitte devant la chaumière aux
coquillages mais vous pouvez revoir
toute cette visite mais aussi des bonus
sur le site internet ter de france
pointent tv et moi je vous retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles rencontres
[Musique]